[Music]
welcome to the show i'm not allowed to
talk about i'm your host definition
durden and this video are breaking down
all the best easter eggs hidden details
and things you missed in fight club
released in 1999 the anti-corporate
mind-bending movie was massively ahead
of its time and though its style twist
and ending have often been mimicked
they've never been duplicated it's very
fourth wall breaking and this even goes
beyond the film itself as when you put
in the blu-ray it doesn't have a title
hinting to one of the big rules in the
movie when you start it up you'll be
taken to what appears to be the menu
screen for drew barrymore's never been
kissed and when i first put the disc in
i genuinely thought i'd been given the
wrong film it completely caught me off
guard to the point i took out the dvd to
make sure i'd put in the right one and
yeah i must admit fincher that he
completely got me like many of you out
there i eventually realized what
i get it it's very clever but this idea
of tearing down a commodity and
commercial image of course ties into the
message of the film itself the film
actually starts with a disclaimer that
appears on screen for a split second and
these are of course common on dvds and
blu-rays most of the time people don't
bother to read them however if you pause
it and check out what it says you'll see
that it's actually a message from tyler
telling you that just by reading this
you're wasting your life he pretty much
berates you for doing everything that
you're told to and that actually reminds
me you should like comment and subscribe
to this video and from here we go to the
title sequence and can hear classical
music
[Music]
which is then cut to play the heavy
theme tune of the actual movie this is
showing us that the foundations of what
we expect in a film are going to be
pushed to the side for this more
contemporary piece we then jump to the
narrator who doesn't even really have a
name take that protagonist and this is
very much to give us the idea that he
isn't really a person and that the
persona he develops slowly starts to
become the main one the opening line of
the film is the character saying people
are always asking me if i know tyler
didn't this is a little meta joke as we
learn that the pair are indeed one in
the same however this reveal is only
brought about at the end of the movie
now before his appearance on the
aeroplane tyler actually appears on
screen at several points for a split
second these are all blinking you'll
miss it moments that work very much in
the same way that the character
describes inserting hidden frames into
films and slowly it sets up the notion
that tyler is infecting the narrator's
mind before he fully materializes for
the clips on screen now we've slowed
down the footage so that you can see
every time he pops up but in the movie
itself it's almost impossible to catch
unless you're looking for it watching it
in the cinema where you can't rewind
stuff i can imagine that many people
didn't even see him and thus tyler is
subliminally inserting himself into the
audience's mind much in the same way
that he does the narrators similar to
this is the idea of corporations now
being part of every aspect of society
and this is slotted into the movie
through the use of starbucks cups
throughout the film these pop up at
several major points and though
initially just thought to be some set
dressing the sheer amount of them goes
far beyond that fight club very much
carries the idea that we must rebel
against the system and like the matrix
this corporate ideology surrounds our
characters at several points even if we
and they are unaware of it in the film
we learn that the first two rules of
fight club are that you do not talk
about fight club these two rules are
exactly the same much like how our two
main characters are in fact the rules of
fight club are very clever as they get
people used to breaking the rules early
on if the rule about not talking about
fight club was actually upheld then the
club would not gain any more members
however we see throughout the film that
it grows exponentially thus we can take
it that everyone is talking about it and
in doing so they're becoming comfortable
with breaking the rules now one rule
that also gets broken that we know for
definite is that meatloaf wears a shirt
we are told that you're not allowed to
but he actually had to don one to cover
up the fact that he was wearing a fat
suit the narrator starts to go to
support groups and when looking through
a list of them there's one that says are
you schizophrenic little clue towards
the end cut to the narrator meeting
tyler for the first time and just before
it the character has a dream that he's
on an airplane as it's about to crash
this idea of his death happening before
he starts what's a new chapter of his
life is of course a clever way to
introduce tyler and we are also given a
hint that the pair are one in the same
when the narrator remarks that they have
the same briefcase the narrator's
apartment is blown up by tyler who prior
to this scene did reveal that he knew
how to build explosives though it is
thought by then all right and that the
pilot light on the stove went out in
respect we know that tyler was behind it
and the clues do start to fit into place
after the police discuss what happened
later in the film the narrator also says
to the investigating officer that the
condo was his life thus it being
destroyed shows a complete change in his
in the introduction to it we see how the
narrator very much sees his identity
being in the things that he owns and
therefore this location being torn down
makes him carve out a new one we can see
amongst the rubble that he also has a
yin and yang table showcasing the
duality between the two characters that
we follow it's not too long before he
goes and calls tyler as he needs a place
to stay he however hangs up the phone
and tyler calls back but if we look
closely on the set we can see that it
doesn't actually receive incoming calls
hinting to us as to what's really going
on here there's also several clues that
tyler isn't a real person and during the
second fight we can see that the crowd
only ever look at the narrator rather
than tyler the character also lives on
paper street which is typically defined
as a street or location that appears on
a map but one that doesn't actually
exist in reality tyler's business card
is also the paper street company and the
logo of it has two identical figures
staring at one another hinting towards
the dual personas the pair start fight
club and one of the more interesting
members of the group is jared leto who
plays angel face during a monologue
tyler says that they were all promised
to be rock stars and he actually looks
at jared who at the time was headlining
with 30 seconds to mars which is a
little bit of irony there now we also
see at one point that a fight is started
with a priest when a man sprays a hose
at him this priest later pops up in the
film as part of fight club showing that
the ideologies are starting to be
embraced by all aspects of society when
the pair get on the bus there's only one
ticket bought hammering harm the idea
that they are only one person there's
also a bystander that walks past tyler
but bumps into the narrator hinting at
the former not really being there they
actually see an advert for calvin klein
underwear and tyler remarks throughout
the film that in wearing underwear in
general that someone is fitting in with
the system throughout the film when he's
shirtless you can actually see that he's
going commando tying in with his easter
egg in a nice little way anyway back to
the clues and when holding a gun to the
back of the shopkeeper's head he also
only answers questions when the narrator
tells him to answer tyler this is
because he is the only one in this
scenario and therefore raymond as we
learn he is called only sees that as
being one person during the car crash
scene we can see that tyler is the one
driving the car and yet when we cut to
the wreckage he actually gets out the
passenger side and pulls the narrator
out of the driver's one tyler also
appears in the hotel welcome video which
further hints to him not being someone
that actually exists in the narrator's
life when tyler gets punched the naroya
actually winces alongside him showing
how the two are affected at the same
time as he gets the chemical burn
tyler's face also starts to sweat along
with the narrators and there are tons of
clues towards this lace throughout the
movie not too long before we meet mahler
and helena bonacota actually told her
makeup artist to apply her makeup with
her left hand because she didn't want it
to seem like carl and knew how to
properly put it on or even cared about
her appearance marla's phone number is
also
555.0134 which just so happens to be
teddy's in the movie memento during the
sex scene between her and tyler she asks
who he is talking to when he answers the
door and i'm telling you yeah the then
alright there are a clues they're all
there now the narrator refers to himself
and tyler as us tomorrow and she asks
what he means by that showing that she's
only aware of one person when on the
phone to the officer investigating the
apartment explosion tyler ramallah
stopped having sex likely because the
narrator was actually on the phone at
this point so he couldn't be doing both
now one of the big questions over the
movie is how marla gets taken to the
tower at the end of the film but when
she gets on the bus we can see that the
driver has a black eye showing that he
was a member of project mayhem at the
end of the movie the narrator says to
tyler i want you to really listen to me
just before he shoots himself tyler
suddenly pricks up as he says this and
this is because earlier in the film the
narrator says d'mala when people think
you're dying they really start to listen
to you the narrator truly believed that
he was going to die at this point and
this is the reason that i think he
manages to kill tyler even though he
only shoots himself in the cheek
throughout the movie we watched as a
person started to deconstruct their own
existence and thus they created another
person in order to fill the void
therefore the narrator trying to end his
own life means that he ends the need for
tyler and it does sort of make sense
when you really start to think about it
the movie itself tackles the idea of old
masculinity such as savage men that want
to fight one another rebelling against
the more sensitive person that they've
been told to be this is shown through
bob who has breasts and the hugging
scene which is a big moment for the
narrator tyler is very much about coming
in and shaking this idea up but we very
much see how this leads to nothing but
destruction and loss tyler is very much
about embracing one's male primal side
but whether this is the right path to
take or not depends on your perception
of society and the world around us
whilst tyler wants people to break free
of the trappings of society he also ends
up creating project mayhem a group of
men with no individual identity that
follow orders without question we learn
that the punishment for exposing this is
castration and this actually has a lot
of depth to it this makes it seem like
tyler wants men who don't fall in line
to be reduced to less than that but the
fact that the narrator ascends beyond
this and decides to reject these ideas
by killing tyler shows that he no longer
embraces these toxic ideologies and has
gone on to become a better man it's a
really complex film and one that still
feels relevant after 22 years making it
in my opinion one of the best movies
ever made now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the movie and if
there's any cool easter eggs that we
missed then make sure you comment below
and let me know if you enjoyed the video
i'd really appreciate it if you hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
each and every day thanks so much for
checking out the video and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the dark
knight which will be linked on screen
right now we go over all the best easter
eggs in the film and it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more by the way i've been the narrator
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care peace